hello again dear viewers you caught me
during my break what even researchers at
the scp foundation need a little down
time now and then and considering they
revoked my playtime privileges with the
living lego and the nerfing gun after
that unfortunate incident in the site 19
break room i've been downgraded to
keeping myself occupied with this little
rubber ball i have a ball perhaps you'd
like to bounce it they say seems
innocent enough doesn't it
[Laughter]
uh have you learned nothing almost any
object even something as innocuous as a
teddy bear or a plastic paddling pool
can hide secrets sure any avid
basketball fan will happily tell you
that ball is life but sometimes when
you're dealing with anomalies a ball can
also
be death such is the case of scp-018
also known as the super ball an anomaly
so powerful that the foundation has even
used it to help recontain
scp-682 during a breach to the untrained
observer it really isn't much to look at
a small red rubber ball around six
centimeters in diameter produced by the
wamo company in 1969. yeah we were as
surprised as you to find out that good
old doctor wondertainment had nothing to
do with this little number you might
also be surprised by just how extensive
the containment procedures are for
scp-018
after all it's rare that a completely
non-sentient anomaly makes its way into
the euclid class this little rubber ball
is kept in a specially made titanium
alloy metal restraint submerged in a
dense polyethylene holding tank filled
with a special endothermic compound that
draws the kinetic energy out of its
surroundings anyone entering the chamber
needs to wear a unique kind of
reinforced plate armor and if scp-018
ever manages to escape its containment
tank nearby personnel are advised to
treat it as they would an active shooter
situation lock yourself in a nearby room
duck down below any cover you can find
and wait for armed containment units to
show up and take control of the
situation at this point you probably
have a lot of questions chief among them
being why is this children's toy being
given more security precautions than
most serial killers the ball was first
discovered when a cleaning and disposal
company was hired to empty out an old
whamma warehouse of some defunct
merchandise one of the movers roy
fishler embraced his inner child when he
saw a red rubber ball sitting among all
the dusty boxes of expired silly putty
and broken remote control robots he
thought to himself ah what's the harm in
having a little fun here it's all going
in the trash anyway this would prove to
be a terrible mistake for all involved
the anomalous property of scp-018 is the
fact that it's able to bounce at 200
percent efficiency every time it's
bounced increasing at an exponential
rate with each bounce unless it stopped
by some equivalent force so when roy
decided to toss that little red ball
onto the ground he unleashed a
destructive force into that warehouse
that was more powerful than he could
ever have imagined with every bounce the
ball increased its height and speed
ricocheting across the floor walls and
ceiling like a bullet run amok and it
was only just getting started the
workers hit the deck as the item that
would later be dubbed scp-018 decided to
put the ball in ballistic it smashed
light fixtures knocked over piles of
boxes smashed through forklifts when one
worker tried to catch it it left a red
hot ball shaped hole in the middle of
his palm it wasn't long before the ball
had built up such speed that the
warehouse could no longer contain it it
blasted out of the wall and rocketed
into a nearby city ready to cause more
abject chaos wherever it went windows
were shattered street lights were
annihilated cars crashed thankfully no
humans were killed by the rampaging
rubber menace but in total five people
were injured and one unfortunate pigeon
was utterly obliterated on impact it
went on for several days with the ball
reaching over 100 kilometers per hour at
several points before finally coming to
a rest at a nearby lake at which point
it was retrieved by foundation personnel
there were two silver linings to this
incredibly strange anomalous incident
the first was as previously alluded to
nobody actually died the second was that
due to the incredible speeds at which
scp-018 move none of the civilian
witnesses had any idea what they just
encountered as far as anomalous
discoveries go this was pretty much as
close to a win as you can get but for
one ambitious researcher it was far more
than just a pleasingly non-violent
initial containment story it was a
doorway to improving the foundation's
technology as a whole meet dr brian
carella he's what you might call a
maverick a blue sky thinker always on
his grind the cornerstone of dr
corello's philosophy was that the
foundation should be making more active
use of its benign anomalies to help
track down and contain their more ornery
foes while everyone else around him
seemed to only see a little rubber
nuisance that was better locked away dr
corella saw the immense potential in
scp-018
namely in providing a vital enhancement
to another piece of foundation
technology the scp a5 armor it goes
without saying that working for the scp
foundation is an incredibly dangerous
job especially if you're part of one of
the foundation's myriad of mobile task
forces the hunt for anomalies can lead
to all kinds of strange and inhospitable
terrains before it was contained
scp-096 was famously captured on an icy
frozen tundra on top of a bleak mountain
because of incidents like this the
foundation had first invested money in
the scp-85 tactical armor suit think of
them like the foundation's answer to the
iron man suit however when dressed in
several hundred pounds of reinforced
metal something important suffers along
the way mobility it isn't exactly easy
to lug all that equipment around and
when an anomaly is heading for the hills
at high speeds being well defended
doesn't count for much if you're already
10 miles behind the target in pursuit
this in dr corella's mind was exactly
where
scp-018 came into play if that little
red ball was built into the foot of an
scp a5 armor suit it could be used to
bounce the operative wearing it to
tremendous heights this would allow them
to not only give chase against
fast-moving anomalies but also cover
difficult terrain and even scale great
heights in a mere instant but it wasn't
just an increase to mobility that
scp-018 integration offered to the
scp-85 suit picture this with scp-018
fused to the sole of the suit's
reinforced metal foot lending at 200
bouncing efficiency it could unleash a
deadly concrete shattering kick the kind
of thing that would leave you singing a
falsetto for the rest of your life if
you were lucky enough to survive it if
you know what i mean to dr corella it
was a match made in heaven it could
increase both the mobility and combat
effectiveness of the suits by a
considerable margin and seeing as
scp-018 literally didn't have a mind of
its own there was no way it could
suddenly go rogue during a mission and
compromise everything just as abel had
done during his stint as a mobile task
force operator before they ran out of
targets for him and he started
slaughtering his own comrades dr corello
was so confident in the efficacy of this
idea he contacted the o5 council
personally to request approval for this
little pet project this approval was
granted on a purely experimental basis
the technology would have to prove
itself before being put into common use
it wasn't exactly what corella wanted to
hear but it was a step in the right
direction he just needed the perfect
opportunity to put them to the test and
then
it came
scp-682 the infamous hard to destroy
reptile breech containment it somehow
adapted a cloaking ability and escaped
further from the site it was being held
at than ever before the next time it was
spotted was over two weeks later causing
pandemonium in the amazon rainforest
devouring tribesmen and wrecking havoc
on the local ecosystem they needed to
get on the scene fast and put that
monster down before the damage it caused
was irreparable and news of the beast in
the amazon leaked out into the local
area and thankfully dr corella had just
the tool for the job field agent
hammersmith was fitted with an scp a5
suit complete with the scp-018
enhancement in his dominant right leg he
was dispatched and immediately the
augmented suit began to show its
efficacy agent hammersmith bounded above
the tree line at incredible speeds using
the hud in the suit's mask to track the
heat signature of scp-682 moving among
the trees below him he'd been able to
bind a tracking collar to the beast's
neck during an earlier engagement but
now the true battle was on his heart was
pounding adrenaline coursing through his
veins but he'd been ensured that even
682 would have a hard time tearing
through his suit's armor a commander
directing him through an earpiece told
him that now was the time to engage
before 682 detected his presence and
began developing countermeasures dr
carrella was watching a live feed from
the control room confident that his
0-1-8 augmented suit would do the job
following his orders to the letter
hammersmith descended down onto 682 from
above however before he could make
contact the reptile swiped him with its
tail sending his body sailing into a
nearby tree however the suit stood firm
he felt the impact but the actual damage
was minimal now it was time for him to
face off against the beast one on one he
didn't have time to be afraid as the
beast descended upon him fangs bared he
gave it a swift kick to the bottom jaw
tearing off half of its face but anyone
who knows
scp-682 would tell you that simply
removing its bottom jaw wouldn't even
slow 682 down it was relentless
attacking hammersmith with its fangs and
jaws it tore deep ruts into the suit's
metal but the suit was still managing to
keep its occupants safe then hammersmith
struck back kick after kick augmented by
the 200 power of the super ball slicing
huge chunks from the reptile's body he
kicked in its chest kicked off its limbs
and with a final mighty kick even
managed to bisect the beast in the
middle of course even that wouldn't keep
it down for long but with the hum of
evacuation and containment helicopters
rapidly approaching hammersmith breathed
a sigh of relief back in the control
room everyone celebrated dr corello most
of all vindicated in his belief that
scp-018 could save the day and then
agent hammersmith without even thinking
rested his right foot on the floor just
that little bit too firmly the sun
bounce set hammersmith a mile into the
air his foundation train composure
evaporated all he could do was scream as
he blasted up into the clouds then began
to plummet back in the control room
everyone could see a live feed of agent
hammersmith hurtling into a nearby lake
and landing with an epic splash while
the regenerating remains of scp-682 were
contained and brought back into the
nearest containment site another team
was sent in to retrieve the heavily
injured agent hammersmith his medical
examination afterward revealed that he'd
suffered two broken legs seven broken
ribs a missing arm and a skull fracture
if he hadn't been wearing that suit his
mangled remains probably would have been
devoured by the local piranhas by now
but despite that minor hiccup in the
plan dr corello was still delighted with
the results and immensely proud of the
little red ball that could in his
closing remarks on the incident he
appended a final note to the scp-018
file reading don't worry it's fixed but
i have some more ideas if i can be
granted the use of some water from
scp-006 as well as some other scps i can
deliver you a set of scp-85 armor and an
agent that can capture any if not all
rogue or unattained scps all i'm waiting
on is your approval now go check out why
everyone wants to eat this corpse
scp-1176 and scp-1025
encyclopedia of common diseases for more
anomalous objects that are full of
surprises